I was dating a Sicilian girl from Flushing, Queens.
And the first time I went to her mom's house for dinner,...
...she was over there at the chopping block, cutting onions.
And she says, "You! Come here!"
Real thick New York accent.
She slaps me a couple times on the cheek, tells me to sit down...
...and proceeds to feed me one of the best Italian meals I've ever had.
I bought a ticket to Italy and I won an apprenticeship at La Vecchia Scuola Bolognese.
Six days a week, 12 hours a day, nothing but handmade pasta.
Pasta fatta a mano.
We ate it for lunch, we ate it for dinner,...
...we made it all day long.
The perfect sheet of pasta is fleeting.
It's an animal: it lives, it breathes, it sweats.
Every day the pasta is different.
And every single one is its own fingerprint.